Fabia Victory against Magnus it's always
sweet but a victory with the black
pieces in 20 minutes that's even better
tell us about the opening phase you
surprised everybody with this move
Knight to A5 what's the story of this
well I prepared this in 2018 for the
match against Magnus I mean we were just
checking like random English lines and I
kind of forgot about this D4 line
basically for a few years and then
recently Magnus started to play for
example he played it in Poland against
watasha he beat him he plays it online a
bit I think he's he's having very good
results with this line
um I didn't check it today but I checked
it like a few weeks ago and it's very
straightforward this this whole Knight
A5 D5 line I mean it kind of gets a bit
crazy but
um but it's very forcing like he has to
take on B4 if he wants to try for an
advantage or even at each point after
Bishop D7 I mean he has to take on B4
so page three I'm sorry queen queen H1
Queen A5 Bishop H3
yeah and now uh this was a draw somehow
I know it's on Queen Vibe it's like cb5
isn't it
or like DB5 actually yeah I don't
remember the details of this at all my
DB5 it's some sort of drawing yeah
this this I kind of remember
position and okay this was a
phrases obviously I'm not remembering
anything but uh it's somehow a draw but
the thing is whatever you're remembering
gives black the advantage so it's
probably a good thing yeah it's it's
very safe for black that's the thing
white has to kind of navigate the way to
equality and I didn't remember the
details but
um I was quite happy when Magnus started
to think because of course white can't
go for this if you don't if you don't
know it
but what he went for is very unpleasant
endgame I mean I was surprised by Knight
C2 but I thought okay bc3 Bishop C5 I
thought he would maybe try Knight B3
Bishop B6 take take and C4 like I
thought okay he
he tries to exchange everything for the
King on C3 and obviously white is
groveling quite a lot here but
hey drawing chances are anyway High um
and that he gave upon and I thought that
it's like very bad like I didn't see how
he's
after 94 I didn't see any move to
survive yeah it's very important that
like Bishop well I don't know very
important but I was going to Castle
um okay he can he can maybe play this
but uh I actually didn't see kingy two
here as I see the computer says white
can still fight on but I thought okay
exchange up yeah and you're definitely a
driver's seat yeah or if he goes for
something like this is obviously quite
pathetic because I'm just a pawn and
even I have a better position so it's
not just up a pawn but also I'm better
and then in the game his Rook got
trapped I mean he he had to
he had to play rookie five okay he
fights on but uh he just bonded his work
as well probably a great start to uh day
two we'll let you go get some rest get
ready for the next game and we'll see
you in a few minutes
thanks uh thank you